welcome to the amazing frog
i don't know why this game has not come
out on any other console yet
it's amazing this game reminds me of
jet set radio future i don't know why
let's shoot up here wonderful
i believe i can frog
i believe oh thank god the cushion no
what are you doing don't land there
oh come on ow where am i going
seriously not the volvo
is he wearing a bikini in there don't
you think that's a little inappropriate
well i guess he doesn't think it's
inappropriate i guess he doesn't carry
it out
you have to appreciate the sound effect
of the running
i'm not saying anything else sounds like
someone is drumming on the back
why should we shoot us go
[Laughter]
oh come on
i can still get you oh god that's too
close i'm free
thank god ow i wait i'm lost
please oh it's the bikini man again
i'm trying to get past this come on
oh god my arm oh god that hurts oh god
that's so painful
stop that ass [ __ ] the
[ __ ]
slap that ass [ __ ]
oh my god i love minecraft i want to
craft
man one time a creeper blew up my house
can you believe it yeah i can't mine
kind
what's going on here what are you guys
doing exactly they're dancing they're
having a hands-off i knew it
[Music]
they are dancing what the [ __ ] what is
happening because i'm still
[ __ ] stopping why am i stuck in this
oh god i'm just sorry woman
oh oh come on enter sewer
i saw a crowbar in it was last night
must find crowbar is that a crowbar
wow that was hard
oh my god jesus i thought i would have
to look everywhere seriously
come on the farts are just sexy it
seriously turns me on this game
i'm going in i can tell
play versus moon no i don't have any
friends sorry
what does it say no farting oops
god damn zambie frogs are after me shoot
them
got you now sami frogs you ain't got
nothing
okay you got me you got me very funny
very funny
damn frogs what the [ __ ] did they do
estella vista
oh my
[ __ ] god is that
or is that not a pigeon on a skateboard
[Music]
okay which game ever kid
do it ollie birdie oh man you're my best
friend
i don't need to play with this game whoa
he can ollie
he can't [ __ ] what [ __ ] flip
man birdie you're the coolest bernie
what are you doing don't touch ratty
it's sensitive see now i have to play
with him
it's your turn show him what you got
whoa
whoa ready got pro skating skills
all right we need to go here
come on come on yes
nailed it shut up again don't shine
do you wanna build a frog i don't really
give a [ __ ]
explode cars to find people you may have
to look noon
and night god damn it
god damn it shut up a [ __ ]
i am out of here right now i'm so
totally out of here right now finally
bros are you ready to go to the moon
because i'm not
well that really that's how you okay
well let's go straight to the moon place
oh my god you know what
i need one of those
whoa moon car
i can drive [ __ ] did oh i always wanted
to be
a frog in space oh
my sorry i always wanted to be a frog
driving
a moon car on the moon and got away
oh god oh okay well all right then
oh my god amazing
it's probably more fun if i had someone
to play with you brother play with me
nice backflip bro what does it say bring
back a robot
wars i agree that show is fun
[ __ ] awesome all right first i'm
gonna have to end the episode here hope
you enjoyed watching go ahead and leave
a like if you did and hit subscribe
comment today i'll see you tomorrow
thousands